well and now they're putting
how do you guys feel about sex ed in
schools
because i'm very anti-sex ed because
this is just my opinion
i think that that's your conversation
your parents should have with you
um and then the argument will always be
well what if you don't have the best
parents well i think
you know with
that we can encourage better parents
without teaching kid because to me it's
like teaching kids how to have sex my 15
year old child doesn't need to be taught
how to have sex
i was very innocent when i was a kid
okay i i remember i was 15 and someone
said the hand job and i didn't know what
that was i was like yeah i was like
what's a hand job
i don't youtube don't don't don't
oh my god there's a mosquito but okay
anyways um
but but i'm like and that that gives old
men and women power to be predatory
because like if you're gonna test the
waters with a child what are you gonna
do with that's like the that's like a
job for a groomer
so what do you guys think it doesn't
work
like the stats don't show that like sex
education is really all that effective
like we we had like mad pregnant chicks
in my high school like what what are you
even i'm done and i do think it gives
children ideas right because you don't
know things until you're taught them
there's like lots of circumstances where
i'm like oh well i heard that in school
so surely you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
see about that like myself and it's like
you're not necessarily smart enough or
old enough to be making those kinds of
decisions so i would agree with you and
then they tell you about like your your
rights and like how to get birth control
and like how to go behind your parents
back basically and it's pretty bad so um
those of you that are watching scarlet
teen is a resource that schools are
pushing to kids that are you know trying
to get like sexual education
it's a scary af website like what
they're pushing to kids it's a
non-profit
and 15 let's pull it up oh it's it's
groomy af roomy af let's see scarlett
yeah i found it let me share
i just want to
see share screen okay
just
oh
whoa there's a section called
there's a what there's a segment in the
top right called quickies
quickies what the f where
the top
yeah
oh my god wait quickies
yeah
how to make new relationships and new
people to pause and have sex more safely
during the pandemic
[Music]
oh my god quickies masturbation oh it's
like the quick definition of what it is
that's what it is it's still pretty
groomy
here here's the thing here's where i
have like the issue with like sex ed in
school right
when it's not based in biology
now they're they're trying to do all
these gender studies right and so
they're telling girls that they can
become
guys and guys thank you girls and if you
want to be non-binary and be a tree you
can be a tree if you want like you can
identify as a cat and pee in the litter
box in the bathroom like
that's what
like that's what the gender that's what
sex said is in school and it is very
groomy and so i think it's very
important that parents
like
teach their children about this at the
proper age right not the birds and the
bees blah blah but like literally based
in biology like
this is what this is this is what that
part is right not
like this is how you masturbate really
quickly um so you don't i don't know so
you don't get blue balls like i don't
know because i don't know what these
people are teaching in the schools i
just know
i just know that what they're teaching
in the schools is that like kids are
coming out more and more and more
confused like that whole tran like
the trans um
ideology there's more trans kids i
p kids that identify as trans i think
it's like up 40 or something i don't
know the stat maybe one of you could
pull it up um and then they're also
and they're also targeting
um
kids with autism and kids that uh you
know on the neurodivergent spectrum and
so it's very predatory
it's not
you know it's
i don't know there's no biology in it
if we if we actually learn biology in
biology class we would learn about these
things but they don't they just want to
push uh these gender studies where you
can be a you can identify as a tree a
nut
freaking plant
i wanna i wanna identify as will smith
so i can leave jada
right
like i want to identify as everything
like i can identify as whatever like you
have to believe me
right i want to identify as a 10. that's
what i want
that's so i've learned to love myself so
i'm a 10 now guys give me my free oil
change give me give me
yeah me too actually i changed it
oh my gosh heidi's crumbling okay well
who wants to host next week
i don't know rebecca should we come to
your channel
we have nothing returned there's there's
nothing happening on my channel
yeah that said it could this could be on
your channel next week
perfect perfect
so yeah we'll have to be at this time my
time pearl is literally it's like two
o'clock in the morning her time because
she's crazy she's like
she's up
till five o'clock i don't know
um but yeah we could do it back up
rebecca calm down
3 30 is typically what i go to
oh my god girl that can't be healthy
well i do a night show like it keeps me
up
do you sleep during the day
yeah i wake up at like noon every day oh
you're like a hooker
i'm sorry you're on that crackhead
schedule yeah you're on the prostitute
schedule why do you think i did
i'm not sure i passed my classes this
semester
you're still going to school like i
thought you just dropped out of school
and started
starting no
because it made you more money than
going to school no no i've been in
school i just have been like failing
so yeah like i haven't been doing school
well but i've been doing it so i mean
166 000 subs over a bachelor's degree
like i just got i got my degree in the
old masters but i got my degree in the
mail and i'm like looking at it like
what the hell like why did i
like i'm not gonna do anything with it
i'm just staring at it like
what
i know that's my problem i don't care
like i just don't but i'm like i need it
for my visa so i gotta finish oh god
fine
boo hoo
first world problems
i know i know okay well so next week
we're doing some rebecca's channel for a
time
stay tuned we'll do it after one of my
shows
wait actually
it's gotta be tuesday or wednesday
because after that i'm going out of town
what do you want to do wednesday
yeah we can do wednesday all right
wednesday
do i have to do like the the welcome to
the show
no you can do your own
that's my intro that i do on my channel
if you like it then you can